Hey everyone, my name is Crawley and
welcome to module one. Let's be entirely
honest. When most people hear the word
insurance, their brains immediately
picture dense stacks of dry legal
paperwork. But insurance isn't just
modern red tape. It is an epic centuries
old story of human community survival.
In this session, we are turning back the
clock to explore the history of
insurance, uncover core definitions, map
out the characteristics of insurable
risks, look at contract structures, and
break down the six general principles
that keep the modern financial world
spinning.
Let's jump into the time machine. Our
first destination is ancient Babylon
around 1700 BC under the rule of King
Hammurabi. Inside the famous code of
Hammurabi, we find the earliest
documented roots of a collective
community safety net. The laws dictated
that if a robber was not caught, the
local community held a structural
obligation to step in and fully
compensate the victim for whatever had
been lost.
Furthermore, if a citizen was kidnapped,
the community was legally bound to pay
exactly one min of silver to their
family as a ransom. Centuries later, the
structural forerunners of modern
commercial insurance shifted to Italy.
Maritime merchants needed a smart way to
protect dangerous sea voyages, leading
to two ancestral credit tools. the
bottom rebond which served as a
financial security agreement using the
physical hull or vessel of the ship as
collateral e and respondentia which
secured loans using the commercial cargo
carried inside the ship. While Europe
was developing commercial bonds, rich
systems of mutual protection were
evolving right here in the Philippines.
Long before modern corporations arrived,
our communities relied on deep cultural
safety nets. First is Paloagan, a highly
popular local pooling of money scheme
that acts as a homegrown mutual fund. It
remains incredibly popular across rural
regions where members regularly pay
daily, weekly, or monthly contributions
to a designated collector. We also rely
on the Bayanihun system, our
foundational cultural paradigm of
collective community support and shared
neighborhood labor. And finally, Abaloy,
a dedicated community collection,
donation, or help fund that serves as an
almsshare or offering to ease a family's
financial burden during collective
affairs or times of grief. Now, let's
head over to London in the year 1689.
A man named Edward Lloyd opened a humble
coffee shop that quickly became the
central meeting place for maritime
sailors, merchants, and ship owners.
Over hot cups of coffee, these
individuals negotiated business deals
and informal marine insurance
agreements. That tiny coffee shop
eventually evolved into Lloyds of
London. Today, it is the world's
absolute leading market for specialist
insurance. But remember this vital
detail for your upcoming quiz. Lloyds is
not an insurance company. Instead, it
functions as a structured association of
private individuals who step forward to
accept and underwrite risks. The formal
timeline of insurance in the Philippines
kicked off in March 1829 when Lloyds of
London officially appointed Stretchham
Murray and Company as its first local
representative. 10 years later in 1839,
Russell and Sturgis was designated by
the Union Insurance Society of Canton as
active agents in Manila. Moving to 1898,
Sunlife of Canada formally established
its local presence. Then came our major
domestic corporate milestones. In 1906,
Yakong Llin Fire and Marine Insurance
Company was founded as our very first
domestic non-life insurance company. And
in 1910, Insular Life Insurance Company
Limited was established, making history
as the first domestic life insurance
company. Today these corporate
frameworks are supported by core local
organizations like PYRA, PLIA, the
Philippine Insurers Club, Philishurers,
the Actuarial Society of the Philippines
and Sound. All of them work to protect
the immense social value of insurance
which optimizes our factors of
production, stabilizes businesses
through indemnification, provides a
solid foundation for our credit systems,
reduces structural worry, and generates
vital capital funds for our national
economy. Stick around because in video
two we are diving deep into the official
playbook of the underwriter.